our next guest says all this talk about
gun control from CNN's totally Orwellian
Town Hall to the president's remarks
pushed him to purchase his first gun
Robert Norman is a writer and a host of
podcasting joins us mr. Owen thanks
coming up thank you for having me Tucker
so I wanted to talk to you not because I
thought your piece I thought was great
but not because it was unique because I
suspect it isn't unique that's kind of
the point I think they're probably a
bunch of people who had the same
reaction that you did explain your
impulse why did you do this yeah you're
right I mean there aren't a lot of
people who I mean there there's a lot of
people who reacted the same way but my
impulse when I wrote the piece was that
I was seeing this argument go on and
seeing the Town Hall seeing everything
go happening on CNN and the reactions
both during it and after no one was
really talking about the issue from a
really complex point of view no one was
admitting on either side that this isn't
a simple issue this isn't a simple
problem so when I when I hear people
scream of you know - not even screaming
but even talking about saying safety is
what's most important and the other side
saying Liberty is what's most important
but neither one admitting that there are
drawbacks there are trade-offs that come
with giving up for giving up liberty for
security and giving up security for
liberty you're always going to have a
trade-off and so when I wrote the piece
I was writing it from that mindset of
what would I rather have what would I
prefer and what do I think is most for
me is most important well that's the
most thoughtful gun purchase of the year
everything you just said I just think
more people than not act on instinct but
I think you've kind of explained what
under undergirds that instinct do you
think you should be trusted with a gun I
think so
I it's interesting because I think that
when it comes to the gun purchase I
didn't come from a point of view that I
was actually excited to purchase a gun
I'm actually cut I mean as I read in my
piece I plan on training my you know I
plan on getting training I plan on
making sure that I take it as
responsibility because I view it as a
duty that's something that we don't
really talk about especially as
civilians living in a in a country
that's founded upon liberty but it's a
duty to carry it and I definitely know
that I don't plan on carrying it until I
know that I can actually protect myself
and protect others and not be a greater
danger to others I think you speak for a
lot of gun owners and I mean there are
people who have guns who shouldn't
probably a lot of them but all the gun
owners I know are very very focused on
safety and responsibility so once you
are trained what do you plan to do with
it I've thought about getting a
concealed carry license I've thought
about you know potentially doing you
know open carry really the the key thing
for me is just knowing that at the very
least I should know how a gun functions
how do to act on a gun how to handle
myself yes gun I've actually gone
through you know safety drills you know
when there's an open shooter drill I've
done those drills I've been told and I
learn and I understand that you run you
hide and if all else fails then you
fight but I think the same thing goes
with with guns is I don't view it as a
as a necessarily in a light gift I know
I don't think it's no know that the guns
are heavy there's a heavy burden
attached I wish we had a gun control
advocate on right now with you to
explain why after everything you've said
you still shouldn't be allowed to have a
gun would be interesting to hear their
perspective and that Robert thank you
for coming on I was really in Thank You
Tucker